yo what's going on boys today we are
going to be doing some more lore hunting
and i thought why not check out the
shaded
castle which is in between volcano manor
and the altus plateau in the capital
city kind of a very interesting place uh
my first playthrough i came here
and i was just getting my ass kicked
so i just decided to leave but really
interesting uh npcs that are roaming
around this area a lot of these guys
right here that are just infected with
poison i can't tell if it's scarlet rot
because this area
does have a huge connection
to melania and her scarlet rot as well
however i think it is an entirely
different type of poison different type
of disease that the family of this
castle has so let's get a little bit
more into that so welcome to castellians
hall in the shaded castle so this is
actually the boss room where you can get
the mary executioner's
sword which reads the storied sword of
house mary the family of executioners
who presided over the shaded castle one
of the legendary armaments elmer of the
briar the bell-bearing hunter snatched
the sword from the site of his looming
execution elmer of the briar is the boss
that we fight in this room of the shaded
castle so he snatched the sword from the
side of his looming execution and
furnished it with the battle skills from
his home of eochad infuse the sword with
energy then fling it forwards in a
corkscrew attack the sword continuously
deals damage while violently spinning
the ash of war that that's speaking of
is
really cool like this this is one of the
coolest weapons in this game
hands down but when you walk into this
boss room it's kind of hard to see once
you start the fight but the boss is
looking at this picture of melania and
then turns around to fight you so
obviously they idolize melania here and
there is some connections that i've
found around the castle that would make
sense to that but before we get into
that i just want to take a look around
the hallways of this castle with all of
these different styles of statues
now i'm not sure who these statues are
made for who they're made of a lot of
them are extremely different i'm
wondering if the shaded castle
was the family that made the
statues america or all of the statues
maybe they're the architectures of all
of elden ring like you can even see a
little statue of america here
before you uh go into the boss fight as
your little checkpoint but i mean there
are statues absolutely everywhere inside
of this castle let me know what you guys
think these statues mean i would like to
think that this family was the ones who
made the statues of the city but i'm
sure it goes a lot deeper than that as
well so i've made a connection with the
mirai
mask which is an npc and a giant golem
fight that you do just outside of the
shaded castle the mirai mask reads mask
in the image of the white-haired young
noble customarily worn by the head of
house mirai and it increases your arcane
the mirai family had a dual history
spanning generations serving as both
executioners and castilians of the
shaded castle this mass bears the
likeliness of the first of their line
now let's take a look at the robe that
that npc was wearing as well the mirai
robe reading robe with a black mantle
across the shoulders customarily worn by
the head of house mirai the sons of
house mirai are all sickly born little
wonder that malay mirai would be so
beguiled by the beautiful and fierce
goddess who was born into rot
so right there we've already made the
connection with house mirai
and melania who is the goddess of the
scarlet rot i'm assuming that they
became friends because they were both
born of these diseases that obviously
caused their a lot of hardship in their
lives because they also have a lot of
the prosthetic arms and even the legs
that melania uses that i'm assuming a
lot of the other npcs in this game use
as well i'm gonna go ahead and take a
guess that house mirai are architectures
builders inventors of armor prosthetics
and the armor that melania will choose
to use since the scarlet rot eats away
at her body she is losing an arm and
pretty much all of her leg having that
relatability and that connection is
probably why they became friends because
it doesn't seem at all that melania was
ever disgraced by her family in fact
they seemed to idolize her very much i'm
sure she had a hard time i don't know
saying making friends in elden ring is
always such a weird stretch because it
seems like nobody
is friends in this game but i'm going to
go ahead and assume that the castle the
shaded castle here of mirai
was taken over after the war i'm not
sure by who but it's clearly in disarray
now when you go down this elevator
you're going to find one of the
followers of melania now it definitely
looks like they're using the prosthetics
that she uses that i'm assuming house
mirai has made for all of melania's
followers of the scarlet rod and again
you look around this area and they're
just statues
everywhere some of them decorated
with autumn leaves you know the leaves
tell a story they always tell us that so
i really would like to hear the
connections you all make with house
mirai
and melania you know it's not like
they're hiding this connection but i
would like to know all of the lore
details of this as well thanks for lore
hunting with me guys and i'll see you in
the next video peace and love